Spring is here and you can now get almost anything you need delivered with Uber Eats. What do we mean by almost? You can't get a well-groomed lawn delivered, but you can get chicken parmesan delivered. Sunshine? No. Some wine? Yes. Get almost, almost anything delivered with Uber Eats. Order now. Alcohol in select markets. See after details. Why do fintechs like Float choose Visa?
春天到了，现在您几乎可以通过 Uber Eats 订购任何您需要的东西。我们说的“几乎”是什么意思？您无法订购修剪整齐的草坪，但可以订购帕尔马干酪鸡。阳光？不行。一些葡萄酒？可以。通过 Uber Eats 订购几乎、几乎任何东西。立即下单。酒精饮料仅在部分市场提供。详情请见售后。为什么像 Float 这样的金融科技公司选择 Visa？
As a more trusted, more secure payments network, Visa provides scale expertise and innovative payment solutions. Learn more at visa.ca slash fintech. I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of The Office with exclusive interviews, behind the scenes details,
作为更值得信赖、更安全的支付网络，Visa 提供规模化专业知识和创新的支付解决方案。欲了解更多信息，请访问 visa.ca/fintech。我是珍娜·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金赛。我们曾一起出演《办公室》，我们是最好的朋友。现在，我们正在为您制作终极的《办公室》爱好者播客。每周，我们将通过独家采访、幕后细节深入探索《办公室》的世界，
and lots of VFF stories. We're the Office Ladies 6.0. Hello. Hello. Welcome to Office Ladies 6.0. Today's show is so fun. It is all about dinner parties gone wrong, inspired by one of our favorite The Office episodes,
以及许多 VFF（非常好的朋友）故事。我们是《办公室女士》6.0 版。你好。你好。欢迎来到《办公室女士》6.0 版。今天的节目非常有趣。它完全是关于搞砸了的晚宴，灵感来自我们最喜欢的《办公室》剧集之一，
The Dinner Party. I mean, so many of you love this classic episode. We love this episode. It's maybe my favorite. I know. I love it. It's definitely top five for me. And, you know, we thought it would be fun to hear from you guys
《晚宴》。我的意思是，你们很多人都喜欢这一经典剧集。我们喜欢这一集。它可能是我最喜欢的一集。我知道。我喜欢它。对我来说，它绝对排在前五名。而且，你知道，我们认为听听你们的故事会很有趣
about your dinner party stories. And boy, did you deliver. Oh, yes. You all wrote in with some unbelievably cringy dinner party stories. I can't wait to share them. But first, I want us to share about an amazing dinner party that we were just at recently that I'm still delighted by.
关于你们的晚宴故事。天哪，你们真的太给力了。哦，是的。你们都写信分享了一些令人难以置信的尴尬晚宴故事。我迫不及待想分享它们。但首先，我想让我们分享一个我们最近参加的精彩晚宴，至今仍让我回味无穷。
It was one of those dinner parties where it was a humongous, huge table, like a giant, long rectangle of just such fun people. There were probably what? Like, it was 26 of us at a restaurant. We got a little private room. And it was to celebrate the wrap of Lee's movie New Year's Rev. Yeah. The cast was there. A bunch of the producers were there. the wrap of Lee's movie, New Year's Rev.
那是一场那种晚宴，桌子巨大，就像一个巨大的长方形，坐满了非常有趣的人。餐厅里可能有，多少人？大概有 26 个人。我们有一个小包间。那是为了庆祝李的电影《新年复仇》杀青。是的，演员们都在那里。一群制片人也在那里。李的电影《新年复仇》杀青。
Yeah, the cast was there, a bunch of the producers were there, some of the crew. Yeah, so we had just finished shooting at the Palladium with Green Day and we all go out to dinner and Angela, you came up for it and Bobby Lee was there and the two of you took over this dinner party. It was amazing. Here's the thing.
是的，演员们都在那里，一群制片人也在那里，还有一些工作人员。是的，我们刚在帕拉迪奥剧院和绿日乐队拍完戏，然后我们都出去吃饭了，安吉拉，你也来了，鲍比·李也在那里，你们俩接管了这场晚宴。太棒了。事情是这样的。
Here's the thing. We sat right in the middle of this long table, and you and Lee were right across from us, and Bobby and I kind of split the table. To his right were all the actors, and to the left were a lot of the crew and producers. Yeah. And him and I were chatting and chatting and chatting and we would sort of engage with the
事情是这样的。我们坐在那张长桌的正中间，你和李就在我们对面，鲍比和我把桌子分开了。他的右边是所有的演员，左边是很多工作人员和制片人。是的。我和他一直在聊天，一直在聊天，我们偶尔会和
actors. And then I said to him, I kind of feel bad that we're not talking to anyone on the left side of the table. And he sort of threw down this gauntlet. He was like, oh, no, no, no. He goes, you can't get in there. Look, they're all talking to each other. They don't want to talk to you. You can't get in there. Good luck getting in that conversation. And I said, oh, yeah. And he was like, yeah, I dare you try to get in that conversation. And so I immediately stood up and I took like my fork to my wine glass and went clink, clink, clink, clink.
演员们互动。然后我对他说，我觉得我们没和桌子左边的人说话，感觉有点不好。他就像扔下挑战书一样。他说，哦，不，不，不。他说，你进不去的。看，他们都在互相交谈。他们不想和你说话。你进不去的。祝你好运，能加入那个谈话。我说，哦，是吗？他说，是的，我敢打赌你试着加入那个谈话。所以我立刻站起来，用叉子敲了敲酒杯，叮、叮、叮、叮。
You guys, she stood up and did the thing where you're gonna do a toast. Like at a wedding. It was so funny, the whole room goes silent. Silent. And I'm thinking, what is she doing? And you, it was so funny, Angela. Angela goes, everyone, I worked three days on this film. And so it seems only fitting that I should speak,
你们这些家伙，她站起来做了那种要敬酒的动作。就像在婚礼上一样。太搞笑了，整个房间都安静了。安静。我在想，她在做什么？而你，太搞笑了，安吉拉。安吉拉说，各位，我为这部电影工作了三天。所以，我觉得我应该发言，
that I should give a toast. And it was so funny. And you gave a very funny toast, a very sweet toast as well. I did. I basically was like, this was such a wonderful project to be a part of. Lee, you did such an amazing job, like just setting the tone for this creative experience. And so when I sat down, the group to the left looks at me and goes, oh, and one of the producers was like, thank you so much for saying that. And look, I am in now with the left side of the table. And I look over at Bobby like, uh-huh. And he goes, damn it.
我应该敬一杯酒。太搞笑了。你敬了一杯非常有趣的酒，也非常甜蜜。是的。我基本上是说，能参与这个项目真是太棒了。李，你做得太棒了，为这次创作体验定下了基调。所以当我坐下时，左边的那群人看着我说，哦，其中一位制片人说，非常感谢你这么说。看，我现在已经融入了桌子左边的人群。我看着鲍比，心想，嗯哼。他说，该死。
And he pops up and he does a clink, clink, clink. And then he goes, I have a toast and I'm gonna say it in Korean. Yes. And then we were all like, oh. And he does his toast and he sits down. And then Angela. I immediately popped back up and I go, click, click, click.
然后他跳起来，叮、叮、叮。然后他说，我要敬酒，我要用韩语说。是的。然后我们都说，哦。他敬了酒，然后坐下了。然后安吉拉。我立刻又跳起来，叮、叮、叮。
And I said, I lived in Indonesia for 12 years from ages two to 14, and I am now gonna give a toast in Indonesian. Everyone was like, wah! It was so great. And then Ignacio, one of the actors stands up, he gives a speech in Spanish. And then the production designer, Adam stands up.
我说，我在印度尼西亚住了 12 年，从两岁到 14 岁，现在我要用印尼语敬酒。大家都说，哇！太棒了。然后伊格纳西奥，其中一位演员站起来，用西班牙语发表了演讲。然后美术指导亚当站起来。
He gives a speech in Italian. Guys, all I can say was this dueling speeches was one of the highlights of the dinner. Angela kicked it all off. It was just such a fun night. It was really fun. Well, that is an example of an amazing dinner party. That was fun.
他用意大利语发表了演讲。伙计们，我只能说，这场决斗式的演讲是晚宴的亮点之一。安吉拉开启了这一切。那真是一个有趣的夜晚。真的很有趣。好吧，这就是一个精彩晚宴的例子。那很有趣。
And there's nothing more fun than an amazing dinner party, which I think is why when a dinner party goes wrong, there's nothing worse. Because you're just all stuck in it. You're in it. So stuck. So let me now set the tone for today, which is dinner party horror stories, with a little refresher. The last time we talked to you all about the dinner party episode on Office Ladies, it
没有什么比一场精彩的晚宴更有趣了，我想这就是为什么当晚宴搞砸时，没有什么比这更糟糕的了。因为你们都被困在里面了。你们身处其中。太尴尬了。现在让我为今天定下基调，也就是晚宴恐怖故事，做一个小小的回顾。上次我们在《办公室女士》中谈论晚宴那一集时，
was in March of 2021. And it really is a fantastic breakdown. We have audio clips from Paul Fiegg and John Krasinski. We got behind the scenes details from writers Jean Stupnitsky and Lee Eisenberg and Steve Carell even read us the summary. I know. I wanna hear it.
是在 2021 年 3 月。那确实是一个精彩的解析。我们有保罗·费格和约翰·卡拉辛斯基的音频片段。我们从编剧吉恩·斯图普尼茨基和李·艾森伯格那里得到了幕后细节，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔甚至为我们读了摘要。我知道。我想听听。
Yeah, me too. You are cordially invited to Michael and Jan's condo for a last minute couples only dinner party. Attendance is limited. We only have six wine glasses. Join Jim and Pam, Angela and Andy, and eventually Dwight and his former babysitter for an evening of drinks, games, music, candles,
是的，我也想。诚挚邀请您参加迈克尔和简的公寓，参加一场临时举办的仅限情侣参加的晚宴。出席人数有限。我们只有六个酒杯。加入吉姆和帕姆、安吉拉和安迪，以及最终的德怀特和他的前保姆，享受一个充满饮料、游戏、音乐、蜡烛的夜晚，
hosobuko, and a home tour like no other. and his former babysitter for an evening of drinks, games, music, candles, osso buco, and a home tour like no other. Snip, snap, snip, snap. Let's get to it. I just love it. I know. You know, I went back and we both rewatched this episode. And you know, the dinner party,
炖小牛膝，以及一场独一无二的家庭参观。以及他的前保姆，享受一个充满饮料、游戏、音乐、蜡烛、炖小牛膝的夜晚，以及一场独一无二的家庭参观。咔嚓，咔嚓，咔嚓，咔嚓。让我们开始吧。我就是喜欢它。我知道。你知道，我回去后我们俩都重看了这一集。你知道，晚宴，
it's just really a perfect combination of cringe plus comedy. And when it was originally released in 2008, I wanted to read you guys what the AV Club had to say about it. Ready? Quote, Oh, the agony! The sweet, sweet comic agony!
它真的是尴尬加喜剧的完美结合。当它在 2008 年首次发布时，我想读给你们听听 AV 俱乐部对它的评价。准备好了吗？引用，“哦，痛苦！甜蜜的、甜蜜的喜剧痛苦！
For me, the best episode of The Office, in both its British and American incarnation, are also the most excruciatingly uncomfortable. On that level, tonight's episode ranks alongside the deposition for sheer squirm-inducing awkwardness. It helps that the show chose a can't-miss premise for its triumphant return to the airwaves. After weeks and weeks of politely and not-so-politely turning down Michael's dinner party invitations, Jim reluctantly acquiesces to spending a sure-to-be painful evening with Michael, Jan, Andy, Angela, and Pam. Tonight's episode honed in on that excruciating evening in the deepest depths of relationship
对我来说，《办公室》最好的一集，无论是英国版还是美国版，也是最令人极其不舒服的。在那个层面上，今晚的这一集在纯粹的令人坐立不安的尴尬程度上，与“证词”一集并列。该剧为重返荧屏选择了这样一个不容错过的前提，这很有帮助。在几周又几周礼貌地和不那么礼貌地拒绝迈克尔的晚宴邀请后，吉姆勉强同意与迈克尔、简、安迪、安吉拉和帕姆度过一个注定痛苦的夜晚。今晚的这一集以手术般的精准度，聚焦于那段处于关系深渊中的痛苦夜晚。
hell with surgical focus. There were no subplots, no random bits of extraneous business to detract from the central gusher of mundane misery. Just pure comic despair from start to finish." I love the phrase, comic despair. I know. Ah, that is great. Well, you know, the idea of making art out of disastrous dinner parties is nothing new.
没有次要情节，没有无关紧要的琐事来分散对平凡苦难中心喷涌的注意力。从头到尾纯粹的喜剧绝望。” 我喜欢“喜剧绝望”这个词。我知道。啊，那太棒了。好吧，你知道，用灾难性的晚宴来创作艺术并不是什么新鲜事。
We got a fan letter from Kristen R. in Buffalo, New York, who said, there's an episode of Cheers called Dinner at Aedish where Frazier and Lilith have Sam and Diane over for dinner and their awkward couple fights ensue. Okay, I was a huge Cheers fan growing up. Oh yeah. I did not remember this episode, so I had to go back and watch. Oh, it's so fun. Oh, I want to see it. So, Frazier and Lilith are a couple now, but you know Frazier and Diane used to be a couple.
我们收到了一封来自纽约布法罗的克里斯汀·R 的粉丝来信，她说，《干杯酒吧》有一集叫《Aedish 的晚餐》，弗雷泽和莉莉丝邀请萨姆和黛安共进晚餐，结果他们发生了尴尬的情侣争吵。好吧，我从小就是《干杯酒吧》的忠实粉丝。哦，是的。我不记得这一集了，所以我不得不回去看。哦，太有趣了。哦，我想看。所以，弗雷泽和莉莉丝现在是一对，但你知道弗雷泽和黛安曾经是一对。
Oh yeah. Okay, they bring Sam and Diane over to their place to host them for this dinner party, and they start bragging that they have total honesty in their relationship. They've told one another about every single person they've ever dated. And of course, Sam is like, that doesn't seem like a good idea.
哦，是的。好吧，他们把萨姆和黛安带到他们家招待他们参加晚宴，他们开始吹嘘他们在关系中拥有完全的诚实。他们告诉过对方他们曾经约会过的每一个人。当然，萨姆觉得，这似乎不是个好主意。
And Diane is like, oh yeah, that's interesting. But then she's like, oh, but I think it's just wonderful. I think it's wonderful that the four of us could be here, even though I was once engaged to Frasier. And this is now news to Lilith. Uh-oh. And so it just sets off, as you can imagine, Lilith just keeps storming into the bathroom.
黛安说，哦，是的，那很有趣。但随后她说，哦，但我认为这太棒了。我认为我们四个人能在这里真是太棒了，尽管我曾经和弗雷泽订过婚。这现在对莉莉丝来说是新闻。哦哦。正如你可以想象的那样，莉莉丝只是不停地冲进浴室。
It's so great. But it made me think of some other dinner parties with amazing, what did the article say? Comic despair from start to finish. And I'm gonna name three of my faves. The opening dinner party for Fleabag season two. Oh my gosh. I don't think a dinner party could go worse than that one.
太棒了。但这让我想到了其他一些晚宴，有着令人惊叹的，那篇文章是怎么说的？从头到尾的喜剧绝望。我要列举三个我最喜欢的。Fleabag 第二季的开场晚宴。天哪。我不认为还有比那更糟糕的晚宴了。
Amazing. I mean, next to this one. Exactly. You know that movie The Breakup with Vince Vaughn and Jennifer Aniston? Remember, he doesn't buy all the lemons for the bowl. Right. For the dinner party. Yes. And then the dinner party is not great. and Jennifer Aniston. Remember, he doesn't buy all the lemons for the bowl for the dinner party. And then the dinner party is not great
太棒了。我的意思是，仅次于这一场。完全正确。你记得那部文斯·沃恩和詹妮弗·安妮斯顿主演的电影《分手》吗？记得吗，他没有为碗买所有的柠檬。对。为了晚宴。是的。然后晚宴就不太好了。和詹妮弗·安妮斯顿。记得吗，他没有为碗买所有的柠檬，为了晚宴。然后晚宴就不太好了
and this is what leads to their breakup. Oh yeah. And finally meet the parents. Is that the one where he says he milked the cat? Oh my gosh. When he has lied and said he grew up on the farm. Yes, uh-huh, yeah. And of course there is probably the prize
而这导致了他们的分手。哦，是的。最后是《拜见岳父大人》。那是他说他给猫挤奶的那一集吗？天哪。当他撒谎说他在农场长大时。是的，嗯哼，是的。当然，这可能是
for the ultimate worst dinner party, the Edward Albee play, Who's Afraid of Virginia Woolf? We got a letter about it from JoLynn Y. in Cleveland, who said, I don't have a dinner party story, but if you're revisiting this episode, can you please discuss the similarities between this and Edward Albee's Who's Afraid of Virginia Woolf? This is my favorite episode, and when it discuss the similarities between this and Edward Albee's Who's Afraid
终极最差晚宴的奖项，爱德华·阿尔比的戏剧《谁害怕弗吉尼亚·伍尔夫？》。我们收到了克利夫兰的乔琳·Y 的一封关于它的信，她说，我没有晚宴故事，但如果你要重温这一集，你能讨论一下它和爱德华·阿尔比的《谁害怕弗吉尼亚·伍尔夫？》之间的相似之处吗？这是我最喜欢的一集，当它讨论它和爱德华·阿尔比的《谁害怕弗吉尼亚
of Virginia Woolf? This is my favorite episode, and when it aired, I immediately thought it must have been inspired by that play. Was it? Well, JoLynn, when we broke down the dinner party episode originally, writer Gene Stupnitsky said that the play was a big inspiration, and writer Lee Eisenberg shared that in fact the original title for the episode was Who's Afraid of Jan Levinson Gould. I mean, that's a great title.
·伍尔夫？》之间的相似之处吗？这是我最喜欢的一集，当它播出时，我立刻想到它一定是受那部戏的启发。是吗？好吧，乔琳，当我们最初解析晚宴那一集时，编剧吉恩·斯图普尼茨基说那部戏是一个很大的灵感来源，编剧李·艾森伯格分享说，事实上，这一集的原始标题是《谁害怕简·莱文森·古尔德》。我的意思是，那是一个很棒的标题。
I would have watched it. I mean, I did watch it. Well, let's take a break, and when we come back, we have fan favorite moments from Dinner Party, plus we share our personal dinner party horror stories and yours. I can't wait. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. I just had a visit with my mom and I was kind of thinking about all the ways that she has
我会看的。我的意思是，我确实看了。好吧，让我们休息一下，回来后，我们将分享晚宴中粉丝最喜欢的时刻，并分享我们个人的晚宴恐怖故事以及你们的故事。我迫不及待了。本节目由 BetterHelp 赞助。我刚和我妈妈见过面，我一直在思考她作为成年人如何真正影响了我的生活。我非常钦佩她的一点是，她总是愿意在需要时寻求帮助。为自己辩护。是的。好吧，你知道，心理健康意识现在正在增长，但仍有进展要做。最近一项调查中，26% 的美国参与者表示他们曾因害怕被评判而避免
really informed my life as an adult. And one of the things that I really admire about her is that she was always willing to ask for help when she needed it. For advocating for herself. Yeah. Well, you know, mental health awareness is growing now, but there's still progress to be made. Twenty-six percent of Americans who participated in a recent survey say they have avoided
寻求心理健康支持。好吧，在这个心理健康意识月，让我们鼓励每个人照顾好自己的身心健康，打破污名。BetterHelp 完全在线。它使治疗变得负担得起且方便，为全球超过 500 万人提供服务。您可以随时免费更换治疗师。我们都在帮助下变得更好。今天就访问 betterhelp.com/office ladies，首次购买可享受 10% 的折扣。那是 betterhelp.com/office ladies。希望您享受您的加拿大航空航班。落基山脉度假，我们来了。哇，这是经济舱吗？免费啤酒、葡萄酒和零食。
seeking mental health support due to fear of judgment. Well this Mental Health Awareness Month, let's encourage everyone to take care of their well-being and break the stigma. BetterHelp is fully online. It's making therapy affordable and convenient, serving over 5 million people worldwide. And you can easily switch therapists anytime at no cost. We're all better with help. Visit betterhelp.com slash office ladies today to get 10% off your first month. That's betterhelp.com slash office ladies. We hope you're enjoying your Air Canada flight. Rockies vacation here we come. Whoa is this economy? Free beer, wine, and snacks.
太棒了！快速免费的 Wi-Fi 意味着我可以在着陆前预订晚餐。有了直播电视，我也不会错过比赛。感觉就像我已经去度假了一样。不错！代表加拿大航空，祝您旅途愉快。Wi-Fi 供 Airplane 会员在配备航班上使用。由 Bell Conditions Supply 赞助，sieracanada.com。
Sweet! Fast free Wi-Fi means I can make dinner reservations before we land. And with live TV, I'm not missing the game. It's kind of like I'm already on vacation. Nice! On behalf of Air Canada, nice travels. Wi-Fi available to Airplane members on Equip flight. Sponsored by Bell Conditions Supply, sieracanada.com.
好了，我们回来了。珍娜，我看了《晚宴》的超级粉丝版。我也是。太棒了。所以我不觉得有什么新场景，但有扩展场景。完全正确。所以如果有一个时刻稍微长一点
All right, we are back. And Jenna, I watched the super fan version of Dinner Party. Me too. It's so good. So I didn't feel like there were any new scenes, but there were expanded scenes. That's exactly right. So if there was like a moment that was a little bit longer
他们没时间放进去，他们就让它播放了。哦，有一个，我最喜欢的，因为我记得拍摄它，就是简的蜡烛室的扩展参观。是的。关于她的蜡烛，我们不得不听的内容更多，太搞笑了。而且，这也意味着吉姆在气味中忍受痛苦的时间更长，并试图屏住呼吸。
that they didn't have time for, they let it play out. Oh, there's one, my favorite, because I remember shooting it, is the expanded tour of Jam's candle room. Yes. There's so much more about her candles that we had to listen to, and it's so funny. And also, just it meant that Jim was in agony of the smells longer and trying to hold his breath.
德怀特和安吉拉之间还有一个延长的告别时刻。太好了。所以如果你喜欢晚宴，并且一直想要多一点内容，我会去看看。我只想再说一次，我们没有得到 Peacock 或超级粉丝剧集的赞助。没有。
There's also a moment between Dwight and Angela that's extended as they say goodbye. So good. So if you love dinner party and you always wanted a little bit extra, I would check it out. I just want to say once again, we are not sponsored by Peacock or the Superfan episodes. No.
但如果你想赞助我们。我们有空，因为我们对这些剧集充满热情。完全正确，完全正确。给我们打电话。是的，叮铃铃。好了，让我们进入这个邮件袋。我有，天哪，
But if you want to sponsor us. We are available because we are enthusiastic about these episodes. Exactly, exactly. Give us a call. Yeah, ringy dingy. All right, well, let's go into this mailbag. I have, oh my gosh,
这一个真的让我笑死了，女士。我想读一下。好的。好的。这是来自弗吉尼亚州的香农·B。香农说，引用，“我和我丈夫被邀请到另一对夫妇家吃晚饭。他们只供应鸡腿，没有配菜，然后开始喝醉，丈夫指责妻子对她的同事有好感。好像事情还不够尴尬，他们决定给那个同事打电话，在我们所有人面前开免提和他说话。不出所料，他们不再在一起了。天哪！他们在晚宴上给同事打了免提电话。
this one really cracked me up, lady. I want to read it. Okay. Okay. This is from Shannon B in Virginia. Shannon says, quote, my husband and I were invited to another couple's house for dinner. They served chicken legs with no sides, then proceeded to get drunk while the husband accused the wife of having a crush on her co-worker. As if things weren't awkward enough, they decided to call the co-worker in question and talk to him on speaker in front of all of us. To the surprise of no one, they are no longer together. OMG! They called the co-worker at the dinner party on speakerphone.
我的意思是，那太疯狂了，但我这封信中最喜欢的部分是晚餐。鸡腿。没有配菜。没有配菜。这是什么饭？我不知道。哦，香农，那让我笑了。好吧，缺乏食物是你们晚宴恐怖故事中的一个共同主题。来自宾夕法尼亚州费城的利兹·K 说，我们被邀请去参加烧烤，他们没有番茄酱。
I mean, that's insane, but my favorite part of this letter is the dinner. The chicken legs. With no sides. No sides. What is this meal? I don't know. Oh, Shannon, that made me laugh. Well, lack of food was a common theme in your dinner party horror stories. Liz K. from Philadelphia, Pennsylvania said, We were invited over for a cookout and they had no ketchup.
嗯。他们觉得这没什么不对。他们只为五个成年人供应了三个热狗、两个汉堡和一块牛排。什么？你们怎么分配那些食物？我知道。你们怎么分配？就像，如果每个人都想吃热狗怎么办？我想你可以把它们切成两半。每个人都可以得到半个热狗。没有番茄酱。还有一些牛排和两个汉堡。同样，没有配菜。
Hmm. And thought nothing wrong with this. And they only served three hot dogs and two burgers and one steak for five adults. What? How do you divide up that food? I know. How do you divide up? Like, what if everyone wanted a hot dog? I guess you could cut them in half. Everyone could get half a hot dog. With no ketchup. And some steak and two burgers. Again, no sides.
没有配菜。我们还收到了来自俄克拉荷马州塔尔萨的艾米丽·R 的粉丝故事，她说，当我还是个孩子的时候，我父母带着我和我姐姐去参加邻居的晚宴。我们大约五点到达，以为六点会吃饭。我们得知晚餐要吃排骨，但他们进度落后，直到晚上 9 点左右才吃饭。天哪。那让你想起了什么？简的炖小牛膝。晚餐供应时，每人只有两根排骨。我姐姐
No sides. We also got a fan story from Emily R. in Tulsa, Oklahoma, who said, When I was a kid, my parents hauled my sister and I to a neighbor's dinner party. We arrived around five, thinking we'd be eating at six. We learned we'd be having ribs for dinner, but they were behind schedule and we didn't eat until almost 9 p.m. Oh my gosh. What does that remind you of? Jan's Osabuco. When dinner was served, they had enough for two ribs per person. My sister
和我很快吃完了我们的份量，然后坐在饥饿的情绪中。没有配菜！又是没有配菜。主人的兄弟然后站起来，绕着桌子走，从每个人的盘子里收集排骨骨头，并开始吮吸已经吃掉的排骨骨头，以获得最后一点碎屑。我们一生中从未见过这个人。我再也不能吃排骨了。我对这段记忆感到非常恶心。” 他拿了每个人的排骨？什么？我不知道。
and I quickly ate our portion and then sat in hangry moods. No sides! No sides again. The brother of the host then stood up, walked around the table, collecting everyone's rib bones off their plates and proceeded to suck the already eaten off of rib bones to get every last morsel. We had never met this man in our life. I can't eat ribs anymore. I'm so disgusted by this memory." He got everyone's ribs? What? I don't know.
然后坐在那里吮吸它们？你知道，安吉拉，当我举办晚宴时，我最大的恐惧之一就是食物不够。我无法告诉你我计划了多少次食物，然后在派对开始前的一个小时，我让李去商店买更多的食物。我惊慌失措，最后剩下的食物太多了。你做过这种事吗？我的意思是，我想我们总是这样做。
And sat there and sucked on them? You know, Angela, one of my big fears when I'm throwing a dinner party is that I'm not going to have enough food. And I cannot tell you how many times I have planned the food and then like in the last hour before the party is supposed to start, I send Lee to the store to buy more food. And I panic and then I end up with way too much food at the end. Have you ever done this? I mean, I think we always do this.
我想我们总是很担心。你知道我在哪里做得过火吗，就是晚餐前的零食。就像乔什总是说，宝贝，停下。因为我说，好吧，我有混合坚果。我有鹰嘴豆泥。我有奶酪盘。我有萨拉米香肠。
I think we're always worried. You know where I go overboard is like the munchies before the dinner. Like Josh is always like, babe, stop. Cause I'm like, okay, I have mixed nuts. I have hummus. I have a cheese plate. I have some salami.
我有蘸酱。我还有三种蘸酱。哦，也许我们应该吃点甜的。他说，别再吃零食了。好吧，关于去你家参加派对，我知道的一件事是我会吃到食物。所以你非常擅长准备晚餐前的时刻。哦，不，是的，不。
I have a dip. I have three more dips. Oh, maybe we should have something sweet. He's like, stop with the munchies. Well, something I know about going to a party at your house is that I am going to arrive to food. So you are very good at having out that pre-dinner moment. Oh, no, yeah, no.
我一进你家门就想吃东西。所以如果你邀请我过去，如果你不马上拿出食物，我的包里会有一根燕麦棒。你是帕姆吗？我是帕姆。我不在乎他们怎么想我。我只是想吃东西。好了。我们收到了来自俄勒冈州汉娜的另一封信。汉娜写信说，几年前，我去参加一个光明节派对，在那里我第一次见到了我伴侣的同事，也就是主人。主人在饭前正在煮釉面胡萝卜。我
I want food the minute I walk in your house. So if you invite me over, if you don't have food out right away, I'm going to have a granola bar in my bag. Are you Pam? I'm Pam. I don't care what they out right away, I'm going to have a granola bar in my bag. Are you Pam? I'm Pam. I don't care what they think about me. I just want to eat. All right. We've got this other letter from Hannah in Oregon. Hannah wrote in and said, A few years ago, I went to a Hanukkah party where I met my partner's coworker, who was the host for the first time. The host was cooking glazed carrots before the meal started. I was
站在厨房里和他们聊天，突然他们用赤裸的手指从锅里拿出一根胡萝卜，咬了一半。但他们没有吃掉剩下的一半胡萝卜，我惊恐地看着他们把吃了一半的胡萝卜放回锅里。不。汉娜说，他们是在检查熟度吗？我的意思是，到底怎么回事？然后，然后汉娜说，在他们把吃了一半的胡萝卜放回锅里后，他们舔了舔手指。
standing in the kitchen chatting with them when out of nowhere they pulled a carrot out of the cooking pot with their bare fingers and bit it in half. But instead of eating the second half of the carrot, I watched in horror as they put the half-eaten carrot back in the pot. No. And Hannah's like, were they trying to check for doneness? I mean, what the heck? Then, then Hannah says, after they put the half-eaten carrot back in the pot, they licked their fingers.
不。我站在那里僵住了，试图处理刚才发生的事情，但在我形成一个完整的想法之前，主人又做了一次。天哪。用一根新胡萝卜。刚才发生了什么。但在我形成一个完整的想法之前，主人又做了一次。天哪。用一根新胡萝卜。他们把舔过的手指伸回锅里，抓起一根新胡萝卜，咬了一半，
No. I stood there frozen trying to process what just happened, but before I could form a complete thought, the host did it again. Oh my gosh. With a new carrot. what just happened. But before I could form a complete thought, the host did it again. Oh my gosh. With a new carrot. They stuck their pre-licked fingers back in the pot, grabbed a new carrot, bit it in half,
然后把剩下的一半胡萝卜扔回锅里，搅拌在一起。汉娜说，我立刻找借口走开了。我找到我的伴侣，疯狂地低声说，别吃胡萝卜。我想知道回家的车程。我找到我的伴侣，疯狂地低声说，别吃胡萝卜。我想知道回家的车程。我需要知道。我知道。汉娜说，不用说，我们没有吃胡萝卜。我们在九点前就离开了，因为许多其他原因，第二年我们没有再回去。
and then dropped the remaining half of the carrot back in the pot and stirred it all together. Hannah says, I immediately made an excuse to step out. I found my partner and frantically whispered, don't eat the carrots. I want to know that car ride home. I found my partner and frantically whispered, don't eat the carrots. I want to know that car ride home. I need to know. I know. Hannah says, needless to say, we did not eat the carrots. We left before nine and we did not go back the next year for many other
而且女士，这让我想到了《晚宴》中迈克尔从浴室回来，简问他是否洗手的那一刻。是的。他说洗了，但他对吉姆和帕姆耳语说没有。然后他就像触摸开胃菜盘子上的所有东西。我的意思是，我知道我刚刚描述了它，但它比超级粉丝剧集稍微长一点。让我们听听。你洗手了吗，宝贝？
reasons. And lady, this made me think of the moment in Dinner Party when Michael comes back from the bathroom and Jan asks if he washed his hands. Yes. And he says yes, but then he whispers to Jim and Pam no. Then he like touches everything on the appetizer plate. I mean, I know I just described it, but it's a little longer than the super fan episode. Let's hear it. Did you wash your hands, babe?
是的，我为你洗了，公主，尽管我只去了一号。是的。我真的没洗手。哦，无论我们听到什么。看起来很好吃。你的手。它们需要被高贵地呈现。
Yes, I did for you, princess, even though I only went number one. Yeah. I didn't really wash my hands. Oh, whatever we hear. This looks delicious. Your hands. They need to be presented royally.
有人吗？给你。好东西。是的，帕姆说，不要用手。女士，他去完一号后没洗手。这让你想起了谁吗？抱歉，男人会触摸他们的“小兄弟”。你不会触摸你的“私密处”。不。听着，男人小便时会处理他们的阴茎，对吧？
Anyone? There you go. Good stuff. Yeah, Pam goes, not the hands. Lady, he didn't wash his hands after going number one. Did it make you think of anyone? I'm sorry, men touch their Mr. Parts. You don't touch your ladybiz. No. Listen, men like handle their penis when they pee, right?
他们不需要触摸它并把它拿出来吗？我假设他们必须把它甩出来。我不知道怎么……是的。谢谢。我的意思是，我不知道它具体是怎么运作的。我不知道机制。但我认为如果你的手碰到了你的私处，你应该洗手。
Don't they have to touch it and get it out? I'm assuming they have to flop it out. I don't know how... Yes. Thank you. I mean, I don't know exactly how it works. I don't know the mechanics. But I think if your hand has touched your bits, you should wash them.
对，因为那样的话，他基本上是用“阴茎手”碰了开胃菜。是的。是的，是的。对。好吧。还有，还有我不敢相信我还要为这个辩护。我说过，有时在自己家里去完一号后，我不洗手。我知道，你知道吗？如果我在别人家里，如果我在公共场合，
Right, because then basically he just touched the appetizers with penis hand. Yes. Yes, yes. Right. Okay. Also, also I can't believe I still have to defend this. I have said that sometimes after going number one in my own house, I do not wash my hands. I know, you know what? If I'm at someone else's house, if I am in public,
如果我在机场，如果我在举办晚宴，我会洗手，大家。你知道吗？好吧。你知道吗，我看到一个东西，就像，我不知道它是在，我忘了在哪里，Buzzfeed，那种东西之一，说就像，10 个有恶心卫生习惯的名人。
if I'm at the airport, if I'm hosting a dinner party, I wash my hands everybody. Do you know? Okay. Do you know, I saw a thing that was like, I don't know if it was on, I forget where, Buzzfeed, one of those kinds of things that said like, 10 celebrities with gross hygiene happens.
天哪。而你在名单上。我在名单上吗？因为那个小便的故事。天哪，天哪。我不知道，这让我想真正地回到新闻周期中。
Oh my God. And you were on the list. Am I on the list? Because of the pee story. Oh my God, oh my God. I don't know, it makes me wanna get genuinely list? Because of the pee story. Oh my God. Oh my God. I don't know. It makes me want to get genuinely in love back in the news cycle.
我不知道哪个更糟。天哪。抱歉。我只是很感激艾莉·坎珀在她的书中写道，她在去完一号后也不总是洗手。在她自己家里，当她不招待客人时。这是圣路易斯的习惯吗？哦，天哪。
I don't know what's worse. Oh my gosh. I'm sorry. I'm just thankful that Ellie Kemper wrote in her book that she also does not always wash her hands after number one. In her own home when she's not hosting. Is it a St. Louis thing? Oh Lord.
别把圣路易斯扯进来。圣路易斯就像，你敢。你会收到邮件的。好了，好吧，我有一个来自加拿大萨斯喀彻温省斯蒂芬妮·M 的粉丝故事。这封信，斯蒂芬妮，让我想起了我自己的晚宴恐怖故事，我稍后会分享。
Don't bring St. Louis into it. St. Louis is like, don't you dare. You're gonna get mail. All right, well, I have a fan story from Stephanie M. in Saskatchewan, Canada. And this letter, Stephanie, reminded me of my own dinner party horror story that I will share in a moment.
但这是斯蒂芬妮的故事。让我想起了我自己的晚宴恐怖故事，我稍后会分享，但这是斯蒂芬妮的故事。斯蒂芬妮说，这发生在 10 多年前，我仍然对整件事感到困惑。我男朋友最好的朋友要结婚了，他们没有举办盛大的活动，而是选择了仅限亲密朋友和家人的活动，晚餐在他们家举行。因为我男朋友是伴郎，
But here is Stephanie's story. reminded me of my own dinner party horror story that I will share in a moment, but here is Stephanie's story. Stephanie says, This happened more than 10 years ago and I'm still baffled by the whole thing. My boyfriend's best friend was getting married, and rather than having a giant event, the couple opted for a close friends and family event only, with dinner to be hosted at their house. Because my boyfriend was in the bridal party,
我没有被邀请参加仪式，但我被邀请参加了晚餐。所以我猜仪式确实只是家人和伴郎，然后晚餐是一件更大的事情。我问我男朋友我应该几点到家吃晚饭，我被告知 5:30。太棒了。斯蒂芬妮说，没问题。我可以做到。我喜欢斯蒂芬妮甚至没有因为没被邀请参加婚礼而感到沮丧。是的，她说，听着，这是他的亲密朋友。我不太认识他们。没关系。你做你的。只要告诉我什么时候到那里
I was not invited to the ceremony, but I was invited to the dinner. So I guess the ceremony was just literally family and bridal party, and then the dinner was a bigger thing. I asked my boyfriend what time should I arrive at the house for dinner, and I was told 530. Great. Stephanie said, no problem. I can do that. I like how Stephanie is not even bumped by not being invited to the wedding. Yeah, she's like, listen, this is his close friends. I don't really know them. It's okay. You do you. Just tell me when to be there
以及在哪里。在更大的庆祝活动上。是的。斯蒂芬妮说，我在 5:20 到达房子，带着一瓶香槟和结婚礼物，发现每个人都已经坐在桌子旁等我了。哦哦。我感到非常尴尬。新娘告诉我，我能来真是太好了
and where. At the bigger celebration. Yes. Stephanie says I arrived to the house at 520 with a bottle of champagne and the wedding gift to discover that everyone was already seated at the table waiting for me. Uh oh. I was mortified. The bride told me it was nice of me to show up
并告诉我坐在哪里。讽刺。我以为是我的错，我为迟到道歉，直到我男朋友证实他被告知是 5:30，而新娘在 5 点钟改变了主意，改成了 5 点。” 她是在搞破坏吗？她不喜欢斯蒂芬妮吗？
and showed me where to sit. Snark. I figured it was my mistake and I apologized for being late until my boyfriend confirmed that he had been told 5.30 and the bride changed her mind to 5 o'clock at 5 o'clock." Is she being like a little sabotagey? Does she not like Stephanie?
我不知道。斯蒂芬妮说，所以我们继续吃晚饭，一切都很顺利。然后在八点钟，新娘决定她累了，要去睡觉。八点钟？在八点钟。在八点钟。客人们很惊讶，开始清理并准备离开。
I don't know. Stephanie says, So we're moving on with dinner and everything's going fine. And then at eight o'clock, the bride decides she's done and going to bed. At eight o'clock? At eight o'clock. At eight o'clock. The guests were surprised and started cleaning up and getting ready to leave.
新娘绕着桌子拥抱每个人并说晚安。因为她每次见到我们时总是拥抱我，我向她表示祝贺并拥抱了她。她翻了个白眼说，我的意思是，如果你想要拥抱的话。什么？
The bride went around the table hugging everyone and saying good night. And since she had always hugged me every time we saw each other, I offered her a congratulations and a hug. She rolled her eyes and said, I mean, I guess if you want a hug. What?
斯蒂芬妮说我们不久后就离开了。这是我经历过的最离奇的晚餐和婚礼晚餐。斯蒂芬妮，我对这个新娘有疑问。我觉得她有什么宿怨之类的。她把靶心对准了你。这个新娘怀孕了吗？或者？因为我只是觉得如果你在办小型婚礼……
Stephanie said we left shortly after. It was by far the most bizarre dinner and wedding dinner I've ever experienced. Stephanie, I have questions about this bride. I feel like she has a vendetta or something. She's got her bullseye on you. Was this bride pregnant? Or? Because I just feel like if you're doing a small wedding...
你要在八点睡觉。八点睡觉，你办小型婚礼，你要在八点睡觉。八点睡觉，你有点暴躁。你想在五点吃饭。你很烦。或者有没有可能新娘曾经对斯蒂芬妮的男朋友有意思？哇。只是说说而已。
You're going to bed at eight. Going to bed at eight, you're a small wedding, you're going to bed at eight. Going to bed at eight, you're a little cranky. You wanna eat at five. You're annoyed. Or is it possible that the bride maybe had at one time had a thing for Stephanie's bow? Wow. Just saying.
不知道。我们不知道。我们不知道。如果我们被邀请了，我们就能在当时检测到妈妈的直觉。我们会问问题的。我真的很想去参加婚礼，你们这些家伙。我知道，你们这些家伙，安吉拉。
Don't know. We don't know. We don't know. If we had been invited, we could have mom detected at the moment. We would have asked questions. I really do want to go to a wedding, you guys. I know, you guys, Angela.
我喜欢婚礼。我想让你知道安吉拉喜欢你们寄来的所有婚礼邀请。我喜欢，我喜欢。她的目标是我们有一天会出现在我们被邀请参加的这些婚礼中的一个。我不知道我们该怎么做，但我会很喜欢。
I love a wedding. I want you to know Angela loves all of the wedding invites that you guys send in. I do, I do. And it is her goal that we are one day going to show up at one of these weddings that we've been invited to. And I don't know how we're gonna pull it off, but I would love it.
我知道。那会让我很高兴。我会做的。我想做像……最终。我想跳舞。我想吃点蛋糕。我想见见阿姨和叔叔。
I know. It would make me so happy. I'll do it. I want to do like... Eventually. I want to dance. I want to eat some of the cake. I want to meet the aunts and uncles.
是的。那是婚礼。你描述的是婚礼。我知道。听起来很棒。描述婚礼。好吧，现在我太好奇了。就像，你说斯蒂芬妮的故事让我想起了你的故事。
Yeah. That's a wedding. You're describing a wedding. I know. Sounds great. Describing a wedding. Well, now I'm so curious. Like, you said Stephanie's story reminds you of your story.
你的晚宴恐怖故事是什么？好了。这是我的晚宴恐怖故事。好的。我是主人。好的。那是很多年前的事了。事实上，我当时没和李在一起。
What is your dinner party horror story? All right. So here is my dinner party horror story. OK. I was the host. OK. This was many years ago. In fact, I was not with Lee.
我嫁给了我的前夫詹姆斯。好的。我做了一个项目。我和项目中的另一位演员变得非常亲近。我们就像，相处得很好。当然。我们是哥们。当然。他太搞笑了，我简直崇拜他。我们说，当这个出来时，我们为什么不一起看呢？我说，哦，我来做东。把你妻子带过来，我们一起看。情侣之夜？是的。看那个项目？
I was married to my ex, James. OK. And I had done a project. And I'd become really close with one of the other actors on the project. We had like, pelled around. Sure. We were buddies. Sure. And he was so funny and I just adored him. And we said, when this comes out, why don't we watch it together? And I said, oh, I'll host. Bring your wife over and we'll watch it. Couples night? Yes. Watch the project?
太有趣了。是的。我们一直就像，我们想成为情侣朋友。不错。所以这是我们的计划。所以我说，太棒了。当节目出来的时候，我给他发了一条信息，我说，为什么你不和你妻子在六点左右过来，然后我们在七点吃晚饭，我们
So fun. Yes. And we had been kind of like, we want to be couple friends. Nice. So this was our plan. So I said, great. And when it was time for the show to come out, I sent him a message and I said, why don't you and your wife come over around six, and then we'll have dinner at seven, and we'll
在八点看节目。太有趣了。太有趣了。太有趣了。所以在当晚的六点钟，詹姆斯和我在客厅里坐着。我摆出了一份熟食拼盘。看看你。是的，我花了很多时间在上面。
watch the show at eight. So fun. So fun. So fun. So at six o'clock on the night of, James and I are sitting in our living room. I've put out a charcuterie spread. Look at you go. Yes, I put a lot of time into it.
我摆好了桌子。我准备好了一份鸡肉晚餐放在烤箱里。这是一份单盘晚餐，这样我可以在晚餐进行、烘烤和烘焙时仍然可以招待客人。我真的考虑得很周到。我太兴奋了。是的，你计划了完美的聚会。然后六点钟到了，他们没来。他们没出现。打电话，发短信，什么都没有？不，什么都没有。六点半。哦。什么都没有。
I had the table set. I had a chicken dinner all ready to go in the oven. It was a one sheet dinner so that I could still visit while the dinner was going and baking and roasting. I'd really thought it out. I was so excited. Yeah, you planned the perfect like hangout. And then six o'clock rolls around and they aren't there. They don't show up. Call, text, anything? No, nothing. Six thirty. Oh. Nothing.
什么，比六点半还晚？快七点了。哦，不。他们还没出现。詹姆斯和我在想，我们该怎么办？就像快七点了。哦，不。他们还没出现。詹姆斯和我在想，我们该怎么办？就像你的熟食板此时看起来有点悲伤。我的意思是，它可能应该放回冰箱里。我们也饿坏了，所以我们一直在吃它，但尽量不留下任何洞。
What, later than six thirty? It's almost seven o'clock. Oh no. And they haven't shown up. And James and I are like, what do we do? Like's almost 7 o'clock. Oh, no. And they haven't shown up. And James and I are like, what do we do? Like your charcuterie board's looking a little sad at this point. I mean, it should probably be back in the fridge. We're also starving, so we've been like picking at it, but trying not to leave any holes in it.
所以它看起来仍然不错。而且，我当时想，我该怎么办？就像我把鸡肉放进烤箱吗？我做鸡肉吗？是的。所以最后，我们收到了一条短信，上面写着，在路上。在路上。就是这样。只是，就是这样。没有理由。什么都没有。在路上。
So it looks still nice. And also, I was like, what do I do? Like do I put the chicken in the oven? Do I make the chicken? Yeah. So finally, we get a text and it says, on way. On way. That's it. Just, that's it. No reason. Nothing. On way.
对。最后，他们出现了。快八点了，女士。不。是的。他们到达时没有道歉。他们什么都没说？什么都没有。没有借口，不抱歉，没有承认这个晚上在两个小时前就开始了。天哪。
Right. Finally, they show up. It's almost 8 o'clock, lady. No. Yes. And they don't apologize when they arrive. They say nothing? Nothing. No excuse, not sorry, no acknowledgement that this evening started two hours ago. Oh my gosh.
我们完全……你就像，发生了什么？发生了什么？他们表现得好像一切都很正常。然后我的记忆是，我们中的一个人说了类似的话，好吧，你们还想吃晚饭吗？是的，因为现在是八点钟。是的。
And we are completely... You're like, what is happening? What is happening? They acted like everything was totally normal. And then my memory is that one of us said something like, well, do you want to still eat dinner? Yeah, cause now it's eight o'clock. Yeah.
他们说，不，我们很好。不，他们说不，我们很好。他们说不，我们很好。他们不想吃晚饭？他们不想吃晚饭。这是一场晚宴。我知道。所以我为我和詹姆斯做了一盘鸡肉，
And they're like, no, we're good. No, they said no, we're good. They said no, we're good. They don't want to eat dinner? They don't want to eat dinner. This was a dinner party. I know. And so I made a plate of chicken for me and James,
我们坐在那里尴尬地吃着鸡肉，看着节目。就像在沙发上，而不是你说的桌子上。不。不。我真的纠结于，我弄错了吗？但我回去看了。短信。
and we sat and awkwardly ate chicken while we watched the show. Like on the sofa, not at the table you said. No. No. And I really wrestled with like, did I get this wrong? But I went back and I looked. At the text.
非常清楚。六点左右。到时候见。是的。没有承认。哦，天哪。天哪。詹姆斯很愤怒。他非常愤怒，以至于当他们终于到达时，他说，告诉他们回家。我说，我不能告诉他们回家。从我的车道上滚出去。所以，我的意思是，你遇到过这个人吗
It was very clear. Six o'clock soon. See you then. Yeah. No acknowledgement. Oh Lord. Oh my God. James was furious. He was so furious that when they finally arrived, he said, tell them to go home. I was like, I can't tell them to go home. Get out of my driveway. So, I mean, have you run into this
自从那以后？我没有。但这里有一件疯狂的事。我给詹姆斯打电话说，詹姆斯，我想在播客上讲这个故事。我不会说那是谁，因为这家伙很有名，而且他现在真的很出名。就像他超级出名。就像我们都知道这是谁一样。是的，非常如此。而且我奇怪地再也没有遇到过这个人。我说，詹姆斯，我要讲这个故事。
person since? I haven't. But here's something crazy. I called James and I said, James, I want to tell this story on the pod. I won't say who it is, because this guy is famous and he's really famous now. Like he's super famous. Like we would all know who this was. Yes, very much so. And I have weirdly never run into this person again. And I said, James, I'm going to tell this story.
首先，詹姆斯对此毫无记忆。他说，天哪，那是一个搞笑的故事。我对那个故事毫无记忆。天哪。他说，顺便说一句，我几年前在某个，我不知道，行业活动上遇到了他。他说，我们一见如故。
First of all, James has no memory of it. He's like, oh my God, that's a hilarious story. I have no memory of that story. Oh my gosh. And he's like, and by the way, I just ran into him a few years ago at some, I don't know, industry event. And he's like, and we hit it off.
首先，詹姆斯对此毫无记忆。他当时说，天哪，这故事太搞笑了，我完全不记得了。天哪。他还说，顺便提一下，几年前我在某个行业活动上偶然遇见了他，我们一见如故。
We're great friends. I really like him. No. And I was like, it didn't come up? The weird dinner party? The awkward, weird night? Oh my gosh. He's like, no, he didn't mention it. He had no memory of it.
我们是很好的朋友。我真的很喜欢他。不。我说，这事儿没提吗？那个奇怪的晚宴？那个尴尬、诡异的夜晚？天哪。他说，不，他没提过。他完全不记得了。
No memory. I mean, I feel like sometimes men can't just kind of forget those things and move on, whereas we hold onto it. Like we're holding a grudge. Like this person, I don't know who it is. You're going to have to tell me, cause now they're going to be on my list too.
完全不记得。我是说，我觉得有时候男人就是会忘记那些事情然后继续生活，而我们却一直记着。就像我们怀恨在心一样。就像这个人，我不知道是谁。你得告诉我，因为现在他们也要上我的黑名单了。
Cause you know, we do that. Like your list is my list. I know this is true. I mean, if I ever ran into this person, it would be the first thing I would think of. Yeah, I mean, I know you can't bring it up. You can't at this point. I guess we've decided to collectively forget about it, which is fine. Maybe there'd be like some kind of snark you could do like just
因为你知道，我们就是这样。你的名单就是我的名单。我知道这是真的。我是说，如果我真的遇到了这个人，这会是我第一时间想到的事情。是啊，我是说，我知道你不能提。现在这个阶段你不能提。我想我们已经决定集体忘记这件事了，这也没关系。也许你可以用某种尖刻的方式，比如
for like gratification. Maybe you could be like, you know, what I love is like a chicken dinner on my lap. And my I eat my lap. While I watch myself on television. Yeah, I always watch myself on TV, but I wait two hours. And then I eat chicken in my lap. See if anything comes across his face. It was very, very strange. That is strange. And I have a weird recollection of them saying something like, like a very brief afterthought apology that was like, oh, sorry, we had a babysitter issue. But like as if you don't want to call,
为了满足一下自己。也许你可以说，你知道，我最喜欢的就是把鸡肉晚餐放在腿上吃。我一边吃一边看电视里的自己。是啊，我总是看电视里的自己，但我会等两个小时。然后我把鸡肉放在腿上吃。看看他脸上会有什么反应。那真的很奇怪。那确实很奇怪。而且我隐约记得他们说了句类似事后道歉的话，就像是，哦，抱歉，我们保姆出了点问题。但就好像你不想打电话，
and then you arrive two hours later, and I've clearly made dinner. It was very strange. Very strange. And you know for sure they have kids? I don clearly made dinner. It was very strange. Very strange. And you know for sure they have kids? I don't even know. I think they do. But maybe they don't.
然后你两个小时后才到，而我显然已经做好了晚饭。那真的很奇怪。非常奇怪。你确定他们有孩子吗？我没……显然已经做好了晚饭。那真的很奇怪。非常奇怪。你确定他们有孩子吗？我甚至不知道。我想他们有。但也可能没有。
Oh my God, Angela, let me tell you who it is. OK. Hold on, everybody. I need to know who it is. I'm going to write it down. Write it down. Here. OK.
天哪，安吉拉，让我告诉你那是谁。好的。等等，大家。我需要知道那是谁。我要把它写下来。写下来。给你。好的。
Hold it up. Lady. What? Lady, I know that this person does not have any children. No, that's not true. No, no children. Are you kidding? I promise you, I promise you, we can Google that person. I have worked with this person.
举起来。女士。什么？女士，我知道这个人根本没有孩子。不，那不是真的。不，没有孩子。你在开玩笑吗？我向你保证，我向你保证，我们可以谷歌一下那个人。我和这个人一起工作过。
What? On a different project. Were they nice to you? Super nice. They only worked one day. Like I was on the project and they did like a day project. Were they nice to you? Super nice. They only worked one day. Like I was on the project and they did like a day play. Right? Okay. This person has no children.
什么？在另一个项目上。他们对你好吗？超级好。他们只工作了一天。就像我在那个项目上，他们做了一天的项目。他们对你好吗？超级好。他们只工作了一天。就像我在那个项目上，他们做了一天的戏。对吧？好的。这个人没有孩子。
I am telling you, because I talked about my kids and he was like, yeah, that wasn't in the cards for me. I am telling you, I promise. That was a bullsh** excuse. These people clearly did not want to be our friends. Why did they even come? I don't know. Why would you come, lie about having kids, not eat our dinner?
我告诉你，因为我谈到了我的孩子，他说，是的，我没打算要孩子。我告诉你，我保证。那是个胡扯的借口。这些人显然不想和我们做朋友。他们为什么要来？我不知道。你为什么要来，撒谎说有孩子，还不吃我们的晚饭？
I mean... Just say, I don't... It's not gonna work out. Unless they're one of these people where their pets are like, they got a babysitter for their pet, I don't know. I don't know. All right, anyway, okay, that's craziness, lady. That's my dinner party horror story.
我是说……直接说，我不想……这行不通。除非他们是那种把宠物当孩子的人，他们给宠物找了保姆，我不知道。我不知道。好吧，不管怎样，好吧，这太疯狂了，女士。这就是我的晚宴恐怖故事。
That is craziness. It was That's my dinner party horror story. That is craziness. It was so cringy and awkward. Once they arrived, it was so cringy and awkward. It was so uncomfortable. Oh, man. It was fun to reconnect with James about it, though. We laughed really hard.
那太疯狂了。那是……这就是我的晚宴恐怖故事。那太疯狂了。那真是太尴尬、太别扭了。他们一到，就太尴尬、太别扭了。太不舒服了。天哪。不过，能和詹姆斯重新聊起这件事还是挺有趣的。我们笑得很大声。
I bet. Well, let's take a break, and when we come back, I have my dinner party horror story. I gave it a name. What is it? Taboo Gone Wrong. Oh, that have my dinner party horror story. I gave it a name. What is it? Taboo Gone Wrong. Oh, that sounds good. Mm-hmm. It was really craptastic.
我敢打赌。好吧，我们休息一下，回来后，我有我的晚宴恐怖故事。我给它起了个名字。叫什么？禁忌游戏出错。哦，那……我有我的晚宴恐怖故事。我给它起了个名字。叫什么？禁忌游戏出错。哦，那听起来不错。嗯哼。那真是烂透了。
["Street Eaters Theme"] ["Street Eaters Theme"] Craving an escape? Bring the vibrant flavors of Mexican street-eat energy to life in your kitchen with Tia Rosa Tortillas. Born in Mexico, Tia Rosa knows how to turn your next taco night at home into the real deal. Find Tia Rosa Tortillas at select grocery stores
["Street Eaters 主题曲"] ["Street Eaters 主题曲"] 渴望逃离吗？用 Tia Rosa 玉米饼在你的厨房里重现墨西哥街头美食的活力。Tia Rosa 源自墨西哥，知道如何让你在家里的下一次塔可之夜变得地道。在精选杂货店寻找 Tia Rosa 玉米饼，
and get the good vibes going. Tia Rosa, Tia Rosa. There are two kinds of people in the world, backward thinkers and forward thinkers. Forward thinkers have plans 15 minutes from now and 15 years from now. They're not just one step ahead, they're 1,000 steps ahead. And when you're a forward thinker, you need a platform that thinks like you do. Workday's AI illuminates decision making and reimagines how you manage your people
让好心情延续。Tia Rosa，Tia Rosa。世界上有两种人，向后看的人和向前看的人。向前看的人对 15 分钟后和 15 年后的事情都有计划。他们不仅领先一步，他们领先了一千步。当你是一个向前看的人时，你需要一个像你一样思考的平台。Workday 的人工智能照亮了决策过程，并重新构想了你如何管理员工
and money for long-term success. Workday, moving business forever forward. Well, we're back and I Googled it. He doesn't have kids. I know. I can't believe he doesn't have kids. I don't know what that was about. I am now haunted, re-haunted by this dinner party.
和资金以实现长期成功。Workday，让商业永远向前。好吧，我们回来了，我谷歌了一下。他没有孩子。我知道。我不敢相信他没有孩子。我不知道那是怎么回事。我现在被这个晚宴困扰，再次被困扰。
But anyway, Angela, I also need to hear your dinner party horror story. Taboo gone wrong. All right. So long, long, long time ago, I'm in acting class. When I first get to LA, I meet this gal, we become friends. She's dating this guy, they have a house together. We go over there for dinner.
但不管怎样，安吉拉，我也需要听听你的晚宴恐怖故事。禁忌游戏出错。好的。很久很久以前，我在上表演课。我刚到洛杉矶时，遇到了这个女孩，我们成了朋友。她在和这个男人约会，他们一起买了一栋房子。我们去那里吃晚饭。
And after dinner, they want to play a board game of some kind. So they say, hey, we just got taboo. Do you want to play taboo? And we're like, yes. And so this is a long time ago. And I just want you guys to know that recently there's been an SNL sketch that is so similar to what happened that Warren and I wonder if you guys to know that recently there's been an SNL sketch that is so similar to what happened that Warren and I wonder if we have told this story in different
晚饭后，他们想玩某种棋盘游戏。所以他们说，嘿，我们刚买了《禁忌游戏》。你想玩《禁忌游戏》吗？我们说，好啊。这已经是很久以前的事了。我只想让你们知道，最近有一个《周六夜现场》的小品，和发生的事情太像了，沃伦和我都怀疑，你们知道，最近有一个《周六夜现场》的小品，和发生的事情太像了，沃伦和我都怀疑
crowds and it made its way to the writers room because when we both saw it we immediately texted each other like oh my god did you see that? So here's what happens. It's me and Warren against this gal and her boyfriend at taboo. We are killing them. We've won like five rounds. We're like, you guys, we can stop. They're like, no, another round.
我们是否在不同的人群中讲过这个故事，然后它传到了编剧室，因为当我们俩看到它时，我们立刻给对方发了短信，说，天哪，你看到了吗？所以事情是这样的。我和沃伦在《禁忌游戏》中对抗这个女孩和她的男朋友。我们简直完胜他们。我们赢了大概五轮。我们说，你们，我们可以停下来了。他们说，不，再来一轮。
We want to play another round. They're starting to get really agitated that they've lost over and over again to us. Okay. But they are at telling each other clues. And it's like, they can't remember anything about each other. Right? So like, let's say the clue is the Grand Canyon. And she's like, we went there and we hiked
我们想再玩一轮。他们因为一次又一次地输给我们而变得非常激动。好吧。但他们在互相给提示。就好像，他们对彼此一无所知。对吧？所以，假设提示是“大峡谷”。她说，我们去过那里，我们徒步
down and we camped. And then we're like, can't say camp. So then she finds other words. By now, Warren and I both know it's Grand Canyon. Anyone in the world would know it's Grand Canyon. And he's like, I don't know what you're talking about. Tell me something. And they're getting so mad at each other. And she's like saying stuff to him like, like the word was like Empire State Building. And all he kept saying over and over was building, building. And she's like, stop saying building. Like they're getting in such a big fight.
下去，我们露营了。然后我们说，不能说“露营”。所以她找了别的词。到现在，沃伦和我都猜到是“大峡谷”了。世界上任何人都知道是“大峡谷”。他说，我不知道你在说什么。告诉我点别的。他们对彼此越来越生气。她说了一些话，比如，词是“帝国大厦”。而他一直重复说“大厦，大厦”。她说，别再说“大厦”了。他们吵得不可开交。
We're like, you guys, we can be done. We can be done. And now it's his turn. Fifth round. He's got this word, he looks at her. He looks at her like he just won the Super Bowl, the happiness in his face. He looks at her and he goes,
我们说，你们，我们可以结束了。我们可以结束了。现在轮到他了。第五轮。他拿到了这个词，他看着她。他看着她，就像他刚刚赢得了超级碗一样，他脸上的幸福感。他看着她说，
oh babe, babe, we can get this one, we can get this one. And she's like, okay, okay. And he goes, all right, this is what I call you all the time. And she goes, stupid. And they go, yeah. And they go, yeah. And they jump up and down and start hugging each other. And we're like, you could have heard a pin drop. Warren and I are like, I call you this all the time.
哦宝贝，宝贝，我们可以猜到这个，我们可以猜到这个。她说，好的，好的。他说，好吧，这是我一直叫你的称呼。她说，笨蛋。他们说，耶。他们说，耶。他们跳起来开始拥抱对方。我们当时觉得，现场安静得连根针掉在地上都能听见。沃伦和我都觉得，我一直叫你这个？
Stupid. Oh my God. We couldn't get out of there fast enough. We're like, well, that was a fun night of games. I mean, that was so long ago. And now there's sort of an SNL sketch a little bit like it. And I'm just like, oh my God, I'm sure many couples have had a complete fight
笨蛋。天哪。我们恨不得立刻逃离那里。我们说，嗯，那真是个有趣的夜晚。我是说，那已经是很久以前的事了。现在有一个有点像它的小品。我只是觉得，天哪，我相信很多情侣都因为
over a game like Taboo. Wow. So there you go. You know, it's kind of interesting to me, Angela, that our dinner party horror stories are like from so long ago, because I think that is your period in your life where you're kind of like trying to figure out
像《禁忌游戏》这样的游戏吵过架。哇。所以就是这样。你知道，安吉拉，我觉得很有趣的是，我们的晚宴恐怖故事都是很久以前的事了，因为我觉得那是你人生中试图弄清楚
who your people are. Yeah, you have to experiment a little, right? Like, who am I going to be friends with? Like, I thought we hit it off on set, but then in real life, it's not really turning into a real friendship or whatever it is. I feel like I don't have any recent dinner party horror stories that I can think of.
谁是你的圈子的时候。是啊，你得尝试一下，对吧？比如，我要和谁做朋友？比如，我觉得我们在片场很合得来，但在现实生活中，它并没有真正变成真正的友谊，或者类似的事情。我觉得我想不出任何最近的晚宴恐怖故事。
I don't think so either because at this point, like you're just more settled in your life. Yeah. Right? And so are your friends. Yeah. Yeah. Well, we got a letter from Grace in Springville, Utah, who I think could probably relate to my taboo night. Here's what she said about her dinner party horror story.
我也不觉得有，因为到了这个阶段，你的生活已经更稳定了。是啊。对吧？你的朋友也是。是啊。是啊。好吧，我们收到了来自犹他州斯普林维尔的格蕾丝的来信，我觉得她可能和我那个《禁忌游戏》之夜有共鸣。这是她关于晚宴恐怖故事的描述。
"'It was a first date with people I had just met in college, but they were good friends with each other. I didn't really want to go in the first place. I was still getting over an ex, but they did not take no for an answer. All I knew was that we were going to someone's place to have dinner. And after dinner, which took three hours
“那是我和刚在大学认识的人的第一次约会，但他们彼此是好朋友。我本来不想去的。我还在走出一段旧情，但他们不接受拒绝。我只知道我们要去某人家里吃晚饭。晚饭后，花了三个小时，
because they wanted to make it together, they said, "'Time for the talent show! I had no idea this was going to happen, and this is something out of my comfort zone. I wanted nothing more than to leave, but they had picked me up for the date and I wasn't near my home, so I was stuck. One couple performed the Cup song from It's Perfect. One boy did an earnest and uncomfortable rendition of Can You Feel the Love Tonight. I pulled a gym and I sent an SOS text to my family and they called with a quote emergency
因为他们想一起做饭，他们说，‘才艺表演时间到了！’我根本不知道会发生这种事，这超出了我的舒适区。我只想离开，但他们开车接我去的，我离家很远，所以我被困住了。一对情侣表演了《完美音调》里的杯子歌。一个男孩深情而尴尬地演唱了《今夜感受爱》。我学了吉姆，给家人发了求救短信，他们打来电话说有紧急情况，
that got me home before it was my turn. I never spoke to these people again. I mean, surprise talent show is a lot to ask of a new friend. Time for the talent show. This really made me think of the dinner party scene when Jan and Michael make everyone play their game of celebrity. Oh, I love it so much. Let's hear the clip Sam actually pulled two different parts of the game for us to hear.
让我赶在轮到我之前回了家。我再也没和这些人说过话。我是说，惊喜才艺表演对新朋友来说要求太高了。才艺表演时间到了。这真的让我想起了简和迈克尔让每个人玩名人游戏的那场晚宴戏。哦，我太喜欢了。让我们听听片段，萨姆实际上为我们剪辑了游戏中的两个不同部分。
No, it's a hump. There's a hump. Joe Kamel! Joe Kamel! different parts of the game for us to hear. You just say 49ers quarterback. All right, Mike. Mike. Mike. My turn. Mike. Mike. Mike. My turn. Mike. Mike. My turn. Babe, can you just like... What?
不，那是驼峰。有个驼峰。乔·卡梅尔！乔·卡梅尔！游戏中的不同部分。你只要说 49 人队四分卫。好的，迈克。迈克。迈克。轮到我了。迈克。迈克。迈克。轮到我了。迈克。迈克。轮到我了。宝贝，你能不能……什么？
Really? Whoa. We're so... What? What? Can you just zoom in now? No, I was making people laugh. No.
真的吗？哇。我们太……什么？什么？你现在能拉近镜头吗？不，我在逗大家笑。不。
Yes. I was watching Jim's face. I was watching Jim. And he was laughing. Look. He's smiling. Look at him. He's laughing. Michael, you're up. Let's go. All right, here we go. This is going to be fun. Ready at him. He's laughing.
是的。我在看吉姆的脸。我在看吉姆。他在笑。看。他在笑。看他。他在笑。迈克尔，轮到你了。走吧。好的，我们开始吧。这会很有趣。准备好，看他。他在笑。
Alright, here we go. This is gonna be fun. Ready? Go! First name is Tom. No, no, no! No names, no rhyming, no sound alike. Okay, okay, you're getting it in my head! First name is Blake. And he goes on a cruise. He goes on a Caribbean cruise. I don't know.
好吧，我们开始吧。这会很有趣。准备好了吗？开始！名字是汤姆。不，不，不！不能说名字，不能押韵，不能说听起来一样的词。好的，好的，你把这些塞进我脑子里了！名字是布莱克。他去游轮旅行。他去加勒比海游轮旅行。我不知道。
Katie Holmes. No! But he's married to her! Oh, Dawson's Creek. No! No, it has to be a real person, Jim! Come on! Okay, no, no, I'm gonna pass. I'm gonna pass.
凯蒂·霍尔姆斯。不！但他和她结婚了！哦，《恋爱时代》。不！不，必须是真实的人，吉姆！拜托！好的，不，不，我要跳过。我要跳过。
Uh, okay! Rhymes with Arnold Schwarzenegger. No rhyming! That's not really a rhyme. Okay. Another clue, another clue. Okay, he's the governor of California, he is the Terminator. Those aren't helpful.
呃，好的！和阿诺德·施瓦辛格押韵。不能押韵！那不是真正的押韵。好的。另一个提示，另一个提示。好的，他是加州州长，他是终结者。那些没用。
Tom Cruise! No! Tag! Gah! Does anybody read the paper? He is the governor of California. He is the Terminator. Those aren't helpful. Junkers! No! Tag! Does anybody read the paper? Oh my god, I remember.
汤姆·克鲁斯！不！标签！天哪！有人看报纸吗？他是加州州长。他是终结者。那些没用。垃圾！不！标签！有人看报纸吗？天哪，我记得。
My turn, he is so amped. And then Jan is just pissing him off. I loved shooting that scene so much. Same. It was so funny. And the way Jim is messing with him. I know. Jim is messing with him. I know Jim is messing with him. Angela legitimately doesn't know any like celebrities. All right. Well, I've
轮到我了，他太兴奋了。然后简一直在惹他生气。我太喜欢拍那场戏了。我也是。太搞笑了。吉姆捉弄他的方式。我知道。吉姆在捉弄他。我知道吉姆在捉弄他。安吉拉真的不知道任何名人。好吧。好吧，我
got a fan story from Jennifer Oh in Cleveland, Ohio. Jennifer Oh, your story. This is very unique. Jennifer says it was my first dinner with my new boyfriend, and now husband, and his parents. And I wanted to make a good impression because I was a senior and he was a junior in high school. I offered to help his mom set the table and she told me to pour drinks for everyone. So I took everyone's order, including hers. Her order was water. Jennifer said I poured all the drinks and then poured her a large glass of water from a pitcher in the refrigerator. We sat down to dinner. Everyone's chatting. It's going great. His mom takes a big swig of water and starts gagging and
有一个来自俄亥俄州克利夫兰的詹妮弗·吴的粉丝故事。詹妮弗·吴，你的故事。这非常独特。詹妮弗说，那是我和新男友，也就是现在的丈夫，以及他父母的第一次晚餐。我想留下好印象，因为我是高三，他是高二。我主动提出帮他妈妈摆桌子，她让我给大家倒饮料。所以我记下了每个人的需求，包括她的。她要的是水。詹妮弗说，我倒了所有的饮料，然后从冰箱里的水罐里给她倒了一大杯水。我们坐下来吃晚饭。大家都在聊天。一切都很顺利。他妈妈喝了一大口水，开始干呕，
falls out of her chair onto the floor, grabbing her throat. No! Yes. Jennifer said we thought she was choking. So I grabbed her glass of water and she smashed it out of my hand and said, vinegar. Because I guess someone should have mentioned that that wasn't a pitcher of water. Earlier in the day, the vinegar lid broke and she poured it into a pitcher and then I served it to her.
从椅子上摔到地板上，抓着喉咙。不！是的。詹妮弗说，我们以为她噎住了。所以我抓起她的水杯，她从我手里打掉，说，醋。因为我想有人应该提一下那不是一罐水。那天早些时候，醋瓶盖坏了，她把它倒进了水罐里，然后我把它端给了她。
Jennifer said, luckily she survived, married her son four years later and we're still together after 30 years. She said her mother-in-law has since passed away. She said, and I will never live down the moment I tried to kill my mother-in-law. I guess this is their family lore of how Jennifer joined the family.
詹妮弗说，幸运的是她活了下来，四年后嫁给了她的儿子，30 年后我们仍然在一起。她说她婆婆后来去世了。她说，我永远无法忘记我试图杀死我婆婆的那一刻。我想这就是詹妮弗如何加入这个家庭的家族传说。
This is in no way that similar, except that I have a pitcher, you know, just it's like a tall pitcher. It's got like a floral theme on it. And I keep it to the right of the kitchen sink because our kids always like, they fix themselves a glass of water and they have like four or five sips
这完全不像，除了我有一个水罐，你知道，它就是一个高高的水罐。上面有花卉图案。我把它放在厨房水槽的右边，因为我们的孩子总是喜欢，他们自己倒一杯水，喝四五口，
and then they're done. Or I'm just going around the house and I'm just collecting cups of water throughout the day. Mm-hmm. And so I've told them if you're not gonna finish your water put it in the pitcher And I'll give it to my plants. Oh, yeah. Yeah, so everyone in my family knows any unused water goes in the pitcher Oh, have you had guests? Drink from the water. I had a friend. Was it me? No Drink from the water? I had a friend. Was it me?
然后就不喝了。或者我只是在房子里走来走去，整天收集剩下的水杯。嗯哼。所以我告诉他们，如果你不喝完水，就把它倒进水罐里。我会给我的植物浇水。哦，是的。是的，所以我家里的每个人都知道任何没喝完的水都会倒进水罐里。哦，你有客人喝过那里的水吗？我有一个朋友。是我吗？不，喝过那里的水吗？我有一个朋友。是我吗？
No! It wasn't you. It wasn't you. And I also didn't see them pour the glass. I came around the corner and they were sort of in close proximity to the pitcher and they had a glass of water. And I said to Josh, I was like, did you get them water? And he goes, no.
不！不是你。不是你。而且我也没有看到他们倒水。我转过拐角，他们离水罐很近，手里拿着一杯水。我问乔什，我说，你给他们倒水了吗？他说，没有。
And I said, did they go to the fridge to get the water? He goes, no. And then we saw the pitcher had been moved. Did you say anything? But they had already drank the water. So you said nothing. I said nothing. Of course you said nothing.
我说，他们去冰箱拿水了吗？他说，没有。然后我们看到水罐被移动了。你说了什么吗？但他们已经喝了水。所以你什么也没说。我什么也没说。你当然什么也没说。
I said nothing. But now I'm paranoid. So as soon as anyone comes in the kitchen, I say to them, do not drink from that pitcher. That is like everyone's backwash, old water for my plants. I pour our unused water into our dog's bowl. Oh yeah, I do that too sometimes, yeah. I think you need a special pitcher
我什么也没说。但现在我变得多疑了。所以只要有人进厨房，我就对他们说，不要喝那个水罐里的水。那是每个人的口水，是我给植物留的旧水。我把没喝完的水倒进狗碗里。哦，是的，我有时也那样做，是的。我觉得你需要一个特别的水罐，
that says for the plants. Or it needs like a little sign with a chain and a little blackboard or something that you write in on it. I'm sure you can find that at Michael's. Or I could just write it on a post-it note and tape it to it. You could, but now I have an idea of what to get you for your birthday.
上面写着“给植物用的”。或者它需要一个小牌子，带链子和一块小黑板，你在上面写字。我相信你可以在迈克尔斯店找到。或者我可以在便利贴上写下来，贴在上面。你可以，但我现在知道你生日该送你什么了。
A special picture that says, for the plants. For the plants, I would love that. Yeah, or a sign or something. Don't get me a sign. You don't want a sign? I want to deal with the sign that I then have to hang on the picture. I'm gonna lose a sign, it's gonna break.
一个写着“给植物用的”特别水罐。给植物用的，我会很喜欢的。是的，或者一个牌子什么的。别给我牌子。你不想要牌子？我不想处理那个我得挂在水罐上的牌子。我会弄丢牌子的，它会坏的。
One of the kids is gonna like- No, you're making a good point. Okay. All right. Well, no dinner party horror story episode would be complete, you guys, without an epic fight between a couple to make everyone cringe. And we got a good letter from Beth in Fredericksburg. She wrote and said, My husband and I went to dinner at a friend from high school's house. She and her husband... Sorry, I read this but then I forgot. Ready? Yes.
其中一个孩子会……不，你说得对。好的。好吧，没有晚宴恐怖故事的剧集是不完整的，伙计们，如果没有情侣之间史诗般的争吵让每个人都感到尴尬。我们收到了贝丝从弗雷德里克斯堡寄来的一封好信。她写道，我和丈夫去高中朋友家吃晚饭。她和她丈夫……抱歉，我读过这个，但后来忘了。准备好了吗？是的。
She and her husband were drunk when we got there. They had a huge Whir of the Roses fight while we sat there in horror, throwing things, screaming. She told him he had a little dick. And he said, well, you weren't complaining two hours ago when you were writing it. We left, and we never saw them again. They got a divorce.
她和她丈夫到的时候已经喝醉了。我们坐在那里惊恐地看着他们吵了一场“玫瑰战争”，扔东西，尖叫。她告诉他他那玩意儿很小。他说，好吧，你两小时前写它的时候可没抱怨。我们离开了，再也没见过他们。他们离婚了。
Shocker. That is like literally Jan and Michael's fight. Uh-huh. I mean, for real. For real. Jan and Michael have many big fights in the dinner party, but I think my personal favorite is, um, when Michael goes out and gets the neon poly sign in the middle of dinner and he hangs it on the wall. And then everyone lights up blue.
真令人震惊。那简直就是简和迈克尔的争吵。嗯哼。我是说，真的。真的。简和迈克尔在晚宴上有过很多次大争吵，但我个人最喜欢的是，嗯，迈克尔在晚宴中途出去拿了霓虹灯啤酒标志，把它挂在墙上。然后每个人都变成了蓝色。
It's so blue. It was so bright. It was so hard not to laugh when that happened. Sam pulled a clip. I think we should listen to it. Oh. OK. That's nice.
太蓝了。太亮了。发生那种事时，很难不笑。萨姆剪了一个片段。我觉得我们应该听听。哦。好的。那很好。
Everybody enjoying their meal? Hey, babe. Yeah? How about we take the beer sign down until our guests leave and then we can discuss it? No. No. I'm gonna leave it up. I think it ties the whole room together. Okay. Jay thinks Hunter's very talented. You know what? I don't think he's that good.
大家吃得开心吗？嘿，宝贝。怎么了？我们要不要在客人离开前把啤酒标志拿下来，然后我们再讨论它？不。不。我要把它留着。我觉得它让整个房间融为一体。好的。杰伊觉得亨特很有才华。你知道吗？我觉得他没那么好。
At least he's an artist. B.F.D. I'm a screenwriter. And I'm a camel maker, but you don't hear me bragging about it! No, all you do is you get me to try to work on my rich friends. For an investment opportunity! Man, I would love to burn your candles! You burn it, you buy it! Oh good! I'll be your first customer!
至少他是个艺术家。去你的。我是个编剧。我是个蜡烛制造者，但你没听我吹嘘过！不，你所做的就是让我尝试为你的富人朋友工作。为了投资机会！天哪，我真想烧掉你的蜡烛！你烧了它，你就买了它！哦，太好了！我会成为你的第一个顾客！
But you're hardly my first! That's not she said! That is a $200 plasma screen TV you just killed! Good luck! Pay me back on your zero dollars a year salary plus benefits, babe! Oh my gosh, lady. Lady, do you know what this just made me realize just now when we're talking about this neon sign?
但你绝不是我的第一个！她不是这么说的！你刚刚毁掉了一台 200 美元的等离子电视！祝你好运！用你那每年零美元的薪水加福利还我钱吧，宝贝！天哪，女士。女士，你知道刚才我们谈论这个霓虹灯标志时，我意识到了什么吗？
What? Okay, you know when you shot the movie New Year's Rev for Lee? Yeah. You're in the bar? Yeah, Bucks. Bucks. So, the production designer Adam, he had a special neon sign made for this fictional bar.
什么？好的，你知道你为李拍电影《新年复仇》的时候吗？是的。你在酒吧里？是的，巴克斯酒吧。所以，美术指导亚当，他为这个虚构的酒吧制作了一个特别的霓虹灯标志。
Oh, I remember it. It hangs over the stage. It's huge. It's in the shape of Oklahoma and it says the word Bucks across it. I think it's orange? Orange neon? We were talking about this dinner we just had to close out the movie and Adam comes up to me and he says,
哦，我记得。它挂在舞台上方。它很大。它是俄克拉荷马州的形状，上面写着“Bucks”这个词。我想它是橙色的？橙色霓虹灯？我们当时正在谈论我们刚刚结束电影拍摄的晚餐，亚当走过来对我说，
Jenna, the Bucks sign, it's gonna be there tomorrow. What do you mean tomorrow? I said, what do you mean the Bucks sign? He's like, Lee didn't tell you? He wanted the neon sign for your house. Lady, it's enormous. I was like, what are you talking about? And he's like, the one in the bar.
詹娜，Bucks 标志，明天会送到。明天是什么意思？我说，Bucks 标志是什么意思？他说，李没告诉你吗？他想把这个霓虹灯标志放在你家里。女士，它太巨大了。我说，你在说什么？他说，酒吧里的那个。
It's going to be there tomorrow. Lady, the box arrived. It's like a small fiat. I haven't. It's so big. I'm thinking, I'm like, where is it going? And I haven't even had a chance to ask Lee, what is your intention for this?
明天会送到。女士，箱子到了。它像一辆小型菲亚特。我还没拆。它太大了。我在想，我在想，它要放哪儿？我甚至还没机会问李，你打算怎么处理这个？
What I assume is a very bright neon sign. And then it's so funny that we just rewatched dinner party because I'm like, is this, where are we putting this? We're gonna be like Michael, fanning myself. I'm having a hot flash. I'm fanning myself. I'm gonna take a picture of you. I'm sorry, everybody.
我假设是一个非常明亮的霓虹灯标志。然后我们刚刚重看了《晚宴》真是太搞笑了，因为我在想，我们要把它放在哪儿？我们要像迈克尔一样，给自己扇风。我正在潮热。我在给自己扇风。我要给你拍张照。抱歉，大家。
The AC is broken today. And it's hot. It's so hot. I'm in a tank top. I didn't want anyone to see my arms, but here I am. There you are, lady. This is the fan Angela got me from Singapore. It's very pretty and you're using it.
空调今天坏了。而且很热。太热了。我穿着背心。我不想让任何人看到我的手臂，但我还是穿了。你就在那儿，女士。这是安吉拉从新加坡给我买的扇子。它很漂亮，你正在用它。
I'm so happy. I'm using it. Well, I guess I'm soon to have a neon sign in my house. I don't know where it's going. I don't know where. Lady, I know your house. I can't even imagine the wall space that could accommodate it. Yeah.
我太高兴了。我在用它。好吧，我想我很快就要在家里装一个霓虹灯标志了。我不知道它要放哪儿。我不知道放哪儿。女士，我了解你的房子。我甚至无法想象能容纳它的墙面空间。是的。
It's really big. I know. Well, listen everybody, I'm burning up in here. We need some air. We need some air. I think that was super fun. Thank you all for writing in your dinner party horror stories. Oh my gosh. They were so fun to read. We were cracking up. Well, to end this episode, I thought I'd share something I saw online
它真的很大。我知道。好吧，听着，大家，我快热死了。我们需要空气。我们需要空气。我觉得这超级有趣。谢谢大家写来你们的晚宴恐怖故事。天哪。读起来太有趣了。我们笑得前仰后合。好吧，在这一集结束时，我想分享一些我在网上看到的东西，
when I was prepping. It's about an office-themed dinner at a restaurant in Minnesota. So I saw this post. A digital creator named Aubrey, AKA OnlyObs, shared this reel and it's titled, A Dinner Party with Michael Scott himself right here in the Twin Cities.
当我准备的时候。那是关于明尼苏达州一家餐厅的办公室主题晚餐。所以我看到了这个帖子。一位名叫奥布里（又名 OnlyObs）的数字创作者分享了这个短片，标题是，“与迈克尔·斯科特本人在双子城共进晚餐”。
Yes, please. The latest themed dining experience at Travail Kitchen is truly one for the books. I went and watched her reel. I could not believe how all out this restaurant goes. If you're an Office fan, I think people would be really tickled by it. Here, I'm going to play a little bit of it, okay? Okay. This was our first time at Travail,
是的，拜托。Travail Kitchen 最新的主题餐饮体验确实值得一记。我去看并观看了她的短片。我简直不敢相信这家餐厅做得有多彻底。如果你是《办公室》的粉丝，我觉得人们会觉得它很有趣。这里，我要播放一点，好吗？好的。这是我们第一次去 Travail，
located in Robbinsdale, Minnesota, and this is the office-themed dinner party. As soon as we were sat, we already had the first course waiting for us, and our first drink got handed to us immediately. And from that point on, the drinks and the food courses were flowing. The whole place was decked out
位于明尼苏达州罗宾斯代尔，这就是办公室主题晚宴。我们一坐下，第一道菜就已经在等着我们了，我们的第一杯饮料也立刻递到了我们手中。从那时起，饮料和食物课程就源源不断。整个地方都被装饰得
as if we were in the office. All of the staff was dressed up. Michael Scott was there. All of our bartenders were named Dwight. This was truly an experience. Okay, so I'm watching that and I saw a Scotch and Splenda. But the food looks like you get to eat actual really good food. I wondered, I'm like, oh, are we eating like steak dipped in wine? Like, what are we eating? Yeah, no, the food looks amazing. Although I did see what it looks like an appetizer that has beets. Yep. And I thought I saw some tiny jello something. Maybe so. But I just thought that was really fun. And I guess Michael Scott's there.
好像我们在办公室里一样。所有的员工都打扮好了。迈克尔·斯科特也在那里。我们所有的酒保都叫德怀特。这确实是一种体验。好的，所以我正在看那个，我看到了苏格兰威士忌和代糖。但食物看起来你确实能吃到真正的好食物。我心想，哦，我们在吃蘸酒的牛排吗？我们在吃什么？是的，不，食物看起来棒极了。虽然我确实看到了看起来像是有甜菜的开胃菜。是的。我想我看到了一些小果冻之类的东西。也许吧。但我只是觉得那真的很有趣。而且我猜迈克尔·斯科特也在那里。
Every waiter is Dwight. I mean, come on. I mean, that seems kind of fun. Well everyone, thank you so much for listening to our dinner party horror stories. I have a request. Okay. I'm going to need another dinner party success story with you and Bobbi Lee. I need another dinner with you and Bobbi Lee sometime soon. Done. All right, you guys, we hope you have a great week and we'll see you next week.
每个服务员都是德怀特。我是说，拜托。我是说，那看起来挺有趣的。好吧，大家，非常感谢你们收听我们的晚宴恐怖故事。我有一个请求。好的。我需要另一个你和鲍比·李的晚宴成功故事。我很快需要和你和鲍比·李再吃一次晚饭。成交。好吧，伙计们，我们希望你们有一个很棒的一周，我们下周见。
See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weiss-Berman and Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubberreat by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
到时候见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》是 Odyssey 的节目，由詹娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的执行制片人是凯西·杰金斯。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗，副制片人是安斯利·巴巴科。Odyssey 的执行制片人是詹娜·韦斯-伯曼和莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由克里斯·巴塞尔混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Rubberreat》。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。